FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Hello.
I'm Florina Muntenescu
for The Developer Show.
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
A stable release of Android
Studio 3.3 is now available.
And it's focused on
refinement and quality.
Included in the release
are a Kotlin update,
a new project wizard update,
the navigation editor, and more.
Check out the posting
in the description
below for the full
list of updates,
some screenshots, and
a link to download.
64-bit CPUs deliver
faster, richer experiences
for your users.
And we want to help
you get ready for them.
So we recently provided
more detailed information
and timelines to make it as
easy as possible to transition
in 2019.
Take a look at the post
for all the details.
GO-JEK and Google
Cloud have recently
announced the release of
Feast, an open-source feature
store that allows themes to
manage, store, and discover
features for use in
machine learning projects.
A link to the GitHub
repo is on the post.
Support for Go on Cloud
Functions is now even better.
The runtime uses the
latest version, Go 1.11,
which includes new
language features
like modules for integrating
third-party dependencies
into your code.
Example code and the link to
the Quick Start are on the post.
Nvidia's newest data
center GPU, the Telsa T4,
is now available publicly
in beta on the Google Cloud
Platform in Brazil, India,
Netherlands, Singapore,
Tokyo, and the United States.
Links to get started
are on the post.
In collaboration
with UC Berkeley,
we recently released
Soft Actor-Critic,
a stable and efficient
deep reinforcement learning
algorithm suitable for
real-world robotics
skill learning.
It's efficient enough to
solve real-world robot tasks
in only a handful of hours.
And it also works on a
variety of environments
with a single set of
[INAUDIBLE] parameters.
Take a look at the post for
the research behind Soft
Actor-Critic and also some
of our recent experiments.
We are searching for open-source
projects and organizations
to participate in the 15th
annual Google Summer of Code,
a global program that
draws university student
developers from around the world
to contribute to open source.
The deadline to apply is
February 6 at 8:00 PM UTC.
Please remember to like,
subscribe and share.
I'm Florina Muntenescu
for The Developer Show.
Thanks for watching.
And we'll see you next week.
SPEAKER: Dev Show.
I got the giggles.
The Dev Show 142 take two.